prévenir vous entriez installez vous est
alors celui ci également c'est la menthe
poivrée celui-ci exactement par rapport
à la dernière fois on a une amélioration
donc le score est passé de 0 à 8
donc on a quand même une amélioration au
niveau de l'odorat s'est pas encore
parfait mais il faut continuer à
s'entraîner il ya 16 stylo quelqu'un qui
sent bien il doit sentir au moins 12
heures
si le patient sans entre 9 et 11 odeurs
on dit qu'il est y pose mik
c'est à dire qu'il a perdu partiellement
l'odorat lorsque le patient sans - ou 8
odeurs on dit qu'il est à nos smic c'est
à dire que le patient est considéré
comme ayant une perte complète de doha
il faut s'entraîner à sentir les odeurs
du quotidien donc les odeurs du
quotidien c'est la tasse de café le
matin c'est les épices avec lesquels on
a l'habitude de cuisiner le cerveau est
en train de réapprendre à détecter les
odeurs et à les associer à ce que c'est
un peu comme si pendant la perte de doha
le cerveau avait oublié qu'elle était
par exemple l'odeur de la rose qu'elle
est l odeur et bien du pamplemousse et
donc en serez entraînant comme ça on
rappelle au cerveau un peu comme quand
on étudie pour être efficace quand on
étudie une matière il faut l'étudier
plusieurs fois et bien pour la perte de
droits c'est la même chose pour pouvoir
permettre au cerveau de détecter
rapidement une odeur et savoir ce que
c'est il faut qu'ils seraient entraîne
beaucoup de fois pour pouvoir être très
efficace
au début je sentais chez sentais
vraiment rien il a je commence à
ressentir donc effectivement les odeurs
sont pas les bonnes
forcément mais ça revient c'est ce qui
me rassure parce que c'était un petit
peu dur et effectivement le docteur le
chien m'a me rassure dans ce sens là la
leçon des odeurs ça veut dire qu'il ya
un processus de récupération qui est
enclenché et qui est en bonne voie et
donc généralement les patients comme
julie ne m'inquiète pas si deux ans
après avoir développé le problème de
doha il ne récupère pas il n'a rien
récupéré alors là on peut commencer à
croire qu'il ne récupérera jamais mais
il faut se donner deux ans de délai pour
la récupération
b
à
il va
ça a commencé par une odeur de cuisine
que ma femme a voulu me faire sentir et
en fait une notion de compte que sa
santé rien si je rentre dans une pièce
et on me dit tu as antibes on ne sent
pas ou un plaqué crâne dans la cuisine
je me sentirais pas on sent à manille
inversement
il ya des moments où c'est effectivement
très déprimant quoi pour être plaisir à
table
donc voilà je mange beaucoup moins
qu'avant j'ai perdu 7 kilos on se sert
pas on se dis pas tiens burger je vais y
aller en effet pas en vidéo faite
[Musique]
c'est le cas l'udc tus
et là j'ai reconnu c'était du citron
billet vert moment où il y avait
absolument rien qui se passe et oui j'ai
envie de dire je pense que le protocole
lui l'essentiel m'a aidé mais là où
c'est un peu encourageant c'est que
exemple l'odeur du pain je commençais à
sur une baguette me dire que tu tiens ça
c'est un peu le pain et ça c'est très
récent
ça fait une semaine ou deux
[Musique]
notre chance a été de rencontrer rasure
donne qui est directeur de recherche en
neurosciences au cnrs et qui nous a
ouvert les quelques études scientifiques
qui existait sur eux
la rééducation olfactives et c'est pour
ça que j'ai voulu vulgariser le
protocole pour que pour le mettre à
disposition de chacun
[Musique]
quand on devient au smic on s'aperçoit
qu'ils aucune solution il ya un vide
médical un vide invite de sociétal
invite scientifique
il n'y a pas de traitement parce qu'il
n'ya pas de recherche ce sens a été mis
de côté et finalement on n'a pas fait le
même travail que sur la vue ou
l'audition avec tous ces appareils que
l'on peut fournir aux gens aujourd'hui
pour les accompagner dans leurs troubles
pour l'odorat il n'y a absolument rien
gal vide médical mais il n'y a pas non
plus la compréhension de vos proches de
vos amis du monde professionnel alors on
tombe dans un monde qu'on ne nous a pas
expliqué
[Musique]